الى شان اخر وقعت القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع بالتعاون مع
السعوديه والولايات المتحده اعلان جدا
الالتزام بحمايه المدنيين في السودان وقد
اتفق الطرفين على الالتزام بسياده السودان
والحفاظ على وحدته كما اتفقا على ان مصالح
سلامه الشعب السوداني هي اولويه رئيسيه
وكذا التزام بحمايه المدنيين في جميع
الاوقات وتسهيل الام مرور الامن لهم
لمغادره مناطق الاعمال العدائيه اضافه الى
الامتناع عن اي هجوم من المتوقع ان يتسبب
في اضرار مدنيه واتخاذ جميع الاحتياطات
الممكنه لتجنب وتقليل الضرر الذي يلحق
بالمدنيين وتضمن اعلانه جد التزام الطرفين
باحترامي وحمايه كافه المرافق الخاصه
والعامه مثل المرافق الطبيه ومنشاه المياه
والكهرباء والامتناع عن الانخراط في
عمليات الاخفاء القصري والاحتجاز التعسفي
للمدنيين وعدم اتخاذ المدنيين دروعا بشريه
اضافه الى ضمان عدم استخدام نقاط التفتيش
في انتهاك مبدا حريه تنقل المدنيين